[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what a weird train
my name is now flew me to tawny I'm a
college sophomore with slight otaku
tendencies
[Music]
right one today
I brought my kid brother back in line
when he started breaking bad so I had
earned the privilege of living at home
allowance included with no need for a
part-time job I got to indulge my otaku
side
that said it certainly wasn't one of
those so-called shut-ins when my
spending money ran out I went to the
library to browse through light novels
that was a completely normal nerd
leaving a completely normal life damn
what the hell until I picked up this
book the four cardinal weapons let's see
in order to save the world from the
waves of apocalyptic catastrophe four
heroes will be summoned from another
world seems like pretty standard light
novel stuff each hero wields a
distinctive weapon a sword a spear a bow
or a shield yeah but a shields not
really a weapon it's more like armor
anyway where's the heroine in this thing
I doubt it - this princess she seems
kind of [ __ ] yeah well at least these
hero guys look pretty damn cool and
impressive
I guess all four of them are the main
protagonists spotlights on sword spear
and bow even the shield hero gets
where's the rest of
fantastic the summoning was a success
with the brave heroes won't you please
save our world from pure evil why these
guys ends up where am i what the hell's
this shield please so brave heroes our
world is in dire need of saving is this
for you what do you mean it's in need of
saving the story behind it all is long
and complicated but suffice it to say
that you are the four cardinal heroes
and you are summoned here using an
ancient ritual Cardinal huh so he thinks
the four of us are what heroes of legend
our world is in a most fragile state and
teeters on the brink of destruction
so we beg you o brave heroes please lend
us your aid
yes I could at least hear you guys ours
forget it I also refuse you can send us
back to our home world right do that and
maybe we'll talk you've thought the four
of us here without our consent don't you
even feel the least bit guilty about it
not to mention if you throw us out as
soon as we restore peace we have done
all that work for nothing how willing
are you to accommodate our requests
depending on your answer we may end up
as your enemies instead of your allies
what's with these guys they're not only
taking all this in stride they've
already started demanding respect and
rewards a good sirs before I say any
more we'd like you to have an audience
with the king of Mel remark you can
negotiate the rewards with him directly
so please all right fine
I suppose we'll consider their offer
sure doesn't matter who we talked to
our demands won't change eh could these
guys be any more smug Wow look this
really is another world huh sure is even
the air feels different it's like how
you'd expect to see it described in some
kind of travel brochure does that mean
you've never traveled outside of Japan
before judging by the breeze I'd say
this place has a fairly standard
Mediterranean climate yeah sure that's
what I meant I just couldn't remember
the word for it
so you young men are the four cardinal
heroes of ancient legend this is the
land of mell remark and I am her King
alt Kreml remark xxxii welcome brave
heroes please identify yourselves Rena
Maki I'm a high school student and I'm
16 years old I'm OTA Suki Tamara college
student 21
I suppose I'm up next Itsuki Koizumi
still in high school and I'm 17 yes that
leaves me my name is Ren Motoyasu and
Itsuki yo King aren't you forgetting
someone
ah mo yes forgive me hey you can't just
say yo king you have to address him with
a little respect
so what then his majesty that might be
too formal hmm King is fine alright
whatever you prefer I am now full media
Thani college students 20 years old now
then I suppose I need to explain why
we've brought you here is he ignoring me
my beloved country of Melrose Park and
the entire world surrounding it are
heading down a path to certain ruin I'm
still kind of pissed about how crappy
the King's treating me but here's the
story in a nutshell
there's an old apocalyptic prophecy on
this world it speaks of a series of
incursions of destructive force these
have come to be known as
waves if the calamities wrought by the
waves are not stopped the world will
meet its end every country here has in
its possession an ancient dragon
hourglass these devices can predict each
waves arrival the first wave washed over
this country not long before we were
summoned between the local Knights and
traveling adventurers they somehow
managed to fend it off however the
subsequent waves will become
increasingly powerful the sands in the
hourglass will trickle as long as the
waves keep coming the second will arrive
in less than a month we underestimated
the potency of the waves once we
actually experienced the first one and
barely survived we realized that only
the four cardinal heroes could counter
them so we followed the legend and
summoned you for but now we have no time
to lose wait a sec isn't this the exact
same story it's in that book okay I
think we get the gist of it anyway I'm
sure you didn't bring us here thinking
we'd save you for free of course not
once you repel all the waves I can
assure you we shall reward you most
handsomely yeah well it would seem we
have no choice but to take you at your
word long as you don't renege we'll work
with you but don't think for a moment
that you contain us exactly we won't put
up with you looking down on us right
what these guys said good lord are they
full of themselves if I can trust that
we have reached an agreeable arrangement
I would ask you brave heroes to now
check your statuses wait what's the
status um yeah are you guys dense it
should have been the very first thing
you noticed when you got here Oh put a
sock in it stop acting like you know
everything don't you see the icon in the
lower right corner of your vision huh oh
hey now I do try focusing your attention
on it like this
only level one well that's really
disconcerting isn't it yeah no kidding
who can tell if we can even fight like
this what is all this exactly
it's called status magic and ability
exclusive to the heroes so where do we
go what's the first step you must set
out on an adventure to develop and
upgrade these legendary weapons you have
been equipped with you mean they weren't
already maxed out when we got them all
someone it's not even technically a
weapon
can't we just wield other weapons until
these are usable suppose we'll have to
figure that out as we go regardless it
looks like we've all got a lot of
training ahead of us
we'll have to level up hard and fast
then once the four of us feel like we're
ready we can form a party one moment
brave heroes huh I neglected to mention
you must each recruit allies and
adventures separately and why is that it
is said that by their very nature the
legendary weapons repel one another if
you try and work together it will
apparently hinder their development
looks like he's telling the truth and
the weapons are translating all the
verbal and visual information into
Japanese for us since the Sun is about
to set rest here for the night and begin
your quest tomorrow in the meantime
we'll gather the best of the best to
form your parties
we have quarters prepared for you all
please sirs right this way
all foreign bellow mark are they sure
about this then that means the shield
hero is here too I guess when you're
heroes of legend you get special
treatment the girl who showed us here
was cute too and though it did taste
unusual our dinner was quite sumptuous
doesn't this kind of seem like a video
game that's cuz it is a video game it's
exactly like emerald online uh never
heard of it huh
seriously it's huge what are you talking
about this isn't some online game it's a
new console game I'm playing called
dimension web you're both wrong
everything about this place is identical
to a VRM
called bravestarr online let's sort this
out
first off Ren do you really mean an
actual literal VR mm oh yeah you guys do
get what he means by that to write a
sci-fi game I'm familiar with explore
the concept yeah I've read about him in
light novels now to be sure let's
compare general knowledge whose face is
on the 1,000 yen bill wait who buzz word
of the year last year favorite voice
actors which country's won world war two
who's the Prime Minister only one
explanation we're all from different
versions of Japan right and they pretty
much don't sound anything alike at all
so there are parallel worlds with
parallel Japan's I thought we might just
be from different eras but it would seem
not huh and I can't believe all three of
you have played video games that are so
much like this world why am I the only
one not familiar with it uh what is it
oh nothing I just assumed it was because
you're the shield hero huh you do well
yeah I mean it only makes sense huh why
is there something wrong with the shield
calm down as the oldest one here let me
bring you up to speed on the basics as
far as I've ever seen the shield er
class that specializes in the shield
uh-huh is for losers because no true
gamers ever play it what how about in
your worlds sorry man shield or suck so
what's the terrain like here I'm not
sure but it looks very similar to what
I'm used to each weapon has its own
ideal hunting ground if we spread out
whatever if I'm too weak I can just rely
on my party and if I'm lucky you might
even have some girls in it
the shields role should be to defend the
party and thwart enemy attacks right and
while my love life back home was lacking
here I might just meet the one it'll be
fine
after all I was chosen for this my
success is all but assured Luke yeah I'm
coming world oh right then we start
questing tomorrow let's head back to our
rooms and get a good night's sleep
do you think they have bats here
[Music]
hell yeah my grand adventure begins
tomorrow morning we have gathered the
greatest warriors in the land these
brave souls will fight the waves
alongside you so how's this work take
turns picking them for our parties dang
there's a real looker here too Oh future
champions the time has come to begin
your journey what they're the ones who
get to choose what huh three there five
there four there yo King I'm loathe to
admit it but even I was not expecting
this no volunteers he must have zero
charisma I've been made aware of an
unsettling rumor as something happened
sir
not exactly the rumor that is quickly
spreading around town is that the so
called shield hero is ignorant of this
world what legend tells us the hero's
arrived with a firm understanding of our
lands and the town's people seem to
think he doesn't meet that criteria
someone must have been eavesdropping
ah [ __ ] last night you think all cuz of
a rumor sure I may not know much but
still regardless you don't need vibrant
how about you give a couple of them to
me I'm a loner you're right
I don't need them whoever cannot cut it
gets left in the dust
what do ya so help me out don't you
think this is unfair yeah I'm surprised
my party is all girls too clearly you're
super broken up about it
jerk it might seem to be the most fair
if we split them up three apiece but if
we try to force the issue it could
destroy everybody's morale mmm so what
you're telling me I have to just go it
alone you guys know I'm a shielder the
class you said was for losers without a
party how am I supposed to grow any
stronger sir hero huh
it's her would you kindly allow me to
switch parties and join the shield hero
are you sure oh yeah what for real she's
actually gonna join my party hmm are
there any others who would be willing to
join master now who me on his quest ah
well so be it we shall have to take
other measures then master now fool me
you will have to recruit for your party
yourself oh right every month we shall
provide each hero with the funds they
require this one time however master now
Foom ease payment will be higher than
the others here are your initial war
chests accept them with our thanks
shield hero receives eight hundred
silver coins while the rest of you each
receives six hundred silver procure all
necessary equipment and set forth sir
[Music]
take good care of her now you hear me
they said we can't help you directly but
I can at least wish you best of luck
with your recruiting until next time so
long bye I beg your pardon shield hero
sir let me introduce myself my name is
mine Souza it's an honor to fight with
you I'm now a fool meet you itani
nice to meet you my pleasure
she's so friendly open and warm I mean
she chose to join me when no one else
would
gotta keep her safe no matter what guess
we should be going huh miss mine
yes sir hero to start I'll show you
around the village
[Music]
I caught a glimpse last night seeing it
up close really drives home how
different this world is let's see here
first place we should visit as a shop
that sells weapons and armor I bet you
can buy some nice stuff I'll take you to
a shop I trust they should have
everything you need all right that
sounds great
so cute
nothing beats having a girl in your car
da this place gets my highest
recommendation Wow a real life weapons
shop welcome good sir
so first time in a weapon shop is it
well you already know how to pick the
best one
thanks but actually she brought me here
mm-hmm
you do look familiar miss have we met
sure I've been in here before
your shop is rather in now after all oh
sweet of you to say so
anyhow who's your companion here with
the funny outfit do you mean you can't
tell sir no are you trying to tell me
he's one of them heroes a shield so yes
that means you must be the dud why are
these dumb rumors about me spreading
like wildfire whatever I can't let that
get me down I am indeed the shield hero
now fool me you itani pleased to meet
you now fool me huh well if you become a
regular I won't give two hoots what you
wield all right kid
good to meet you know that that's out of
the way could you provide sir here with
his equipment needs our budget is around
250 silver left to right that's iron
magic iron magic steel and silver iron
in ascending order of price all quality
soars guaranteed Wow with one of these
even I could share wait what
what the heck is going on I have no idea
it looked like they just blew out of
your hand
yeah but why rule violation
what the hell
how do I fight with just a shield it
appears that besides this shield I'm not
allowed to use any other weapons how
does that work that hmm at a glance it's
like any other small shield does this
thing not come off yeah I can move it
around my body but I can't find a way to
remove it that's strange I can sense a
great amount of power in here but my
appraisal magic doesn't really tell me
much more oh thanks for showing me
something interesting anyway
wanna buy some armor hey now you're
starting to look the part at least mmhmm
yeah thank you how much do you want for
it
heroes discount 120 silver and the
buyback price well let's see if it's
still in mostly new condition I'd offer
you a hundred silver buyback price once
you grow strong enough you really won't
need this armor anymore you don't want
to get ripped off when you come to sell
it back makes sense I guess all right
excellent I'll throw in some innerwear
to show my thanks those where shall we
had to next sir hero off to do battle
yeah time to level up my adventure
finally begins
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow there's no limit to how much you can
absorb that must be part of a legendary
weapons power yeah and it must be why I
don't feel pain when I'm bitten either
but before I can upgrade to a better
shield it looks like I'm gonna need a
lot more fodder oh I see by the way are
these orange balloon fragments worth
anything can we sell them yes but at
most they'll likely only fetch one
copper coin each seeing Hal Ren
destroyed them they must be really weak
yes that's all they're worth that should
be enough shield fodder for now the nice
thing is as I level up then my shield
should evolve too let's call it a day
then we should stop back in at the
weapons shop if we can buy some new
equipment for me we'll get even further
tomorrow sounds fair enough
gear for the lady hmm you'll certainly
be much stronger decked out with some
good equipment right this might get
expensive so I suppose I should start
haggling now really seems our hero
fancies himself a comedian 80% off dolt
20 extra why is it going up 89% off
anyone who tries to haggle before even
seeing the goods deserves to pay double
yeah yeah ninety percent off twenty nine
percent more stop racing it a hundred
percent off cuz I'm just giving it away
so how much is all that at 60% off 480
silver with the discount that's the best
I can offer that'll leave us with two
hundred silver hey mine would you mind
downgrading just a bit I don't know how
much ends and other expenses cost yet I
will be fine sir hero the stronger I am
the more loot we can collect for
monsters right this will keep us going
there's the other world trope I've been
waiting for yeah fine whatever you say
m'lady
alright shopkeeper we'll take all these
thanks a ton young hero gotta say you
have a real nose for good deals
thank you sir hero by the way do you
know of any places around town that'll
buy these fragments there are shops that
specialize in monster goods they'll buy
most of those things off you great thank
you
castle was delicious too but a pub is
where you experience real other world
cuisine glad you're enjoying your meal
the meadow we fought in today was over
here right yep tomorrow we'll be heading
to La fun village which lies beyond this
map and past laufen village we'll find a
dungeon that's perfect for rookie
adventurers but dungeon we won't make
very much money there but it's an
excellent spot for you to work on
leveling up interesting now that I have
new equipment and with you defending me
it should be a walk in the park
thank you mine you've been a wealth of
information no problem by the way sir
hero we have all this wine here aren't
you going to drink some
I'm not into alcohol oh that's too bad
this is a really fantastic vintage after
the long day we've had I'd love to share
it with you all of a sudden she's twice
a seductive but I'm sorry but I really
just don't care for it who's that sell
well too bad
that's a hero for you I suppose uh what
do you mean this country is a matriarchy
no man who's from here would ever dare
turn down a drink offered by a woman
really guess I'm not very good at
picking up on this kind of stuff oh
don't worry you'll learn I'm glad we got
to discuss our plans for tomorrow I
think I'll turn in early tonight is that
okay
of course I'll head up after I finish
your wine
although drinking alone gets so lonely
oh hey mine thanks again for joining up
with a shield hero who can't fight I
declined tonight but I swear I'll make
it up to you someday it's totally fine I
mean it I'll see you in the morning sir
hero pleasant dreams yeah good night two
hundred silver coins left two rooms a
thirty copper each per night and meals
for two at five copper each that leaves
a little over one hundred ninety nine
silver acting like such a stereotypical
Japanese tourist stashing money like
this oh holy crap there what a day I
wonder how it truly feels to kill a
monster today I just ran around popping
balloons but still I really am in
another world is that moto yeah so eat
Suki time for bed off to an early start
and all
[Music]
okay downstairs for some breakfast and
then head out god it's gone the silver
the chainmail and even my old clothes
that I was keeping from when I get to go
back home no way I was robbed in my
sleep
my NOPA up all our money and equipments
been stolen you still asleep in there
wake up we're in serious trouble you
guys are nice from the castle right I'm
glad you're here listen I have a shield
here oh yes yeah that's right
the King has issued a summons for you
boy you're to come with us what the
hell's going on here fine hey are you
okay
what's wrong yo King while I was
sleeping all of the money and equipment
I had other than this shield was stolen
from my room please sir
find the thief enjoy to filth what's
this about mine I'm sorry to ask my dear
but would you mind repeating your
testimony for us again last night but
shield hero forced his way into my room
he was thinking drunk he grabbed me and
picked me down huh huh he said something
like the night is still young
next thing I knew he was tearing all my
clothes off what
what the hell if she hadn't asked me to
wait until dawn and call the Knights I
would have gladly cut you down myself
what are you talking about I went
straight to bed after dinner last night
and I don't drink wait that's my Gmail
that you're wearing you thieving bastard
give it back
who are you calling a thief mine gave
this armor to me as a special gift when
I met her at the pub yesterday to think
the Cardinal sealed hero would commit
the greatest sin in this country see in
male remark even attempted sexual
assault on a woman is punishable by
death if you weren't a hero
you'd be executed at once executed I
promise you I'm the one being wronged -
you're not hurt I didn't do it and if
you're so convinced I did then show me
some proof when we performed a search of
the shield hero's room we um we found
this sir strewn across his bed
oh so that thing wasn't here when I woke
up what a terrible shame I worried
something bad might happen but hoped you
knew better Jess he thinks a hero can do
whatever the hell he wants to get away
with it it's not even the least bit true
I swear this world is not some
consequence-free playground for you know
your players goundrill what the hell is
this why is this happening
mine why why would you lie like that
we're supposed to be a party
I see
joining me was just a ruse so she could
destroy me right here it was all a lie
when she smiled at me or acted kind Fick
[Music]
fire you tricked me
shut your mouth you criminal
up yours pretty boy you did all this to
steal my money and equipment I'll bet
you two planned it together yeah come to
think of it the only thing my never
called me was sir hero but she's calling
Motoyasu by name if that's not proof
they were in it together I don't know
what is refusing to admit he's guilty
and making nonsensical accusations I
know what you're thinking and you're
right he doesn't deserve a shred of
mercy I knew it it was a mistake to
summon all four together at once
exactly they shouldn't have summoned the
shield hero at all but who could have
known he'd be such scum again it's just
about the shield has to be because I'm
the shield hero because I'm weak they're
trying to knock me down and some crazy
attempt to make themselves look better
disgusting these people are all filthy
disgusting trash this country's people
don't believe in me either
why should I raise a finger to help them
[Music]
fine I don't care anymore and why should
I just send me back to my world summon a
new shield hero or whatever you want I'm
out
screw this world seriously why don't I
get ripped away from my home just to go
through this so you're gonna run away as
soon as things start to get tough you
really are scum after all you've done
how could you even think about
abandoning your job I say let the coward
run on home who wants to fight alongside
a rapist good now send me back to my
world this instant believe me I would
like nothing more than to kick you out
but legend says that no new heroes may
be summoned until all four of the
original Cardinal heroes meet their end
what'd he say it's insane so you're
telling me I can't even go home not yet
but there is only one way you may return
home fight off all the incoming waves
but sir does that mean we'll have to
fight alongside a criminal like him
screw you guys
who needs you figure out how to handle
the waves my way what'll it be King are
you gonna have me rot in jail in between
every wave there's no more time before
the next wave so I won't be imprisoning
you scum or not you're still a hero and
one of the only beings left who can
fight them all off but news of your
crime is already spreading among the
people that is your punishment
you should never expect to be allowed to
lead a decent life in this country
yeah clearly this is what you wanted
right shove it up your ass
hey wait one second I'm the weak one
remember I don't have a second to waste
just like that all my money my respect
and my trust was gone
I lost everything
Hey shield bro so I heard what you did
to that girl you were with
I had a punch you in the face you're
against me too hang on what gives
I thought you were already to punch me
no I changed my mind
good you were about to lose your life
there hold up a second you won't make it
very far dressed like that
consider this a parting gift how much
does it matter since you're broke but
let's call it a clearance sale and save
five copper yeah fine I'll come pay you
someday sure kid don't die
[Music]
[Applause]
I finally hit level two but I had to
fight all night
let's see for these little things how
does one copper for every pair sound
yeah sure you got yourself a deal
splendid things come again welcome sir
good how much for all of these Oh
balloons are they
looks like 20 of them by my count how
does one copper sound for the entire lot
I heard you offer the last guy one
copper forever too did I no I don't
recall that you must understand I do
have a business to run
that's so can I assume that these will
fetch a better price then they're quite
Lively look I'm not trying to whip you
off here all I'm asking of you was a
fair market price is it personal if
there may be some reason you might have
for hating me
sounds like we have a deal bit huh if
you buy from me consistently I'll even
give you a small discount rather than
trying to policeman rights right
consider it done sir and as much as I'd
like to refuse the exchange of money for
goods have nothing to do with any crimes
you may or may not have committed and
one more thing you need to spread the
word around to all of the other
merchants tell him that any trader who
decides to mess with me will get totally
covered in bite marks don't you worry
I'll tell everybody to a fruitful
relationship
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
aren't these new shields so does that
mean that by mastering abilities I get
to keep them even after I upgrade to
another one leaf shield go
it really is just like a game it can
improve the plants quality wow this is
really good stuff where did you find
these in the forest right outside the
castle didn't you know
sure but I've never seen anything
there's such high quality I was certain
that was much more average
[Music]
since that day nothing I eat has any
flavor
oh great shield hero will join your
party if you want yeah that's right
thank your lucky stars okay but how
about we go ahead and discuss the terms
up front your thing your pay will be
entirely performance-based do you know
what that means
no not a clue means you'll be paid
according to the loot we get on our
quest and since I'm the leader
I'll be keeping at least 40% I'll split
up the rest among you guys at my
discretion if you do nothing of value
then you can expect to be paid nothing
what the hell that means if you get a
wild hair up your ass you could end up
keeping it all for yourself I promise to
pay you if you do your job assuming you
can hmm let's go get us some equipment
bossman buy your own equipment I have
nothing to gain by doing that for you
what forget the party crap and just hand
over your money now see if you'd only
said that to begin with you could have
saved us all a whole bunch of time Yeah
right who knew it'd be so easy
oh I have real good defense but no
offensive ability without it I can't
defeat monsters and because of that I
can't farm experience points and since I
can't farm I can never raise my
offensive ability I'm stuck in a loop
it's clear you don't have any what luck
I have exactly what you need if you're
offering me party members I'll pass
party members no no what I'm offering
you is a service I believe you'll find
far more convenient and what would that
be
interested are we leave me alone you've
got that look in your eyes that I just
adore you're every bit the man the
rumors said you'd be rumors huh so then
you know who I am of course I do
brave shield hero sir if my offer
interest you follow me we can discuss it
further
right this way
so what exactly are you offering me
can't you tell by just looking they're
slaves my boy
no way yes way I run a slave trading
business what would make you think I'd
want to own slaves oh I don't know the
fact that they could neither line or
betray their master we keep all our
slaves in line by placing them under the
effects of occurs a strong steel based
curse if they misbehave it can take the
very lives what do you say all right
show me what you've got I knew you had
exactly what it takes to be your most
wonderful patron
don't shoot I can assure you they still
are technically tell me more I don't
know much about this world creatures
that look mostly humans aren't what we
refer to as ME humans they're mostly
used as surface or manual labour beasts
men are deme humans whose appearance
leans more towards the animal side
they're often used as bodyguards or
Gabaldon as participants and death
matches they see but they both fall
under the same category indeed and since
this country practices human supremacy
and deme humans are thought to be closer
to monsters life can be quite hard for
them here as such they're treated as
slaves
[Music]
[Music]
eating distant people and I find our way
to the light come for my way in this
lingering word search evil dancer the
one that I can trust in I'm just
[Music]
baby better never lie to hide your love
account supply
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]